i
ah
[Música]
[Aplausos]
par de sogas
bueno
hace unos meses
yo inicié a dar clases de yoga
yo tengo 15 años practicándolo
y una amiga mía me pidió que enseño en
su taller
yo soy estudiante de yoga
pero yo he recibido tantos beneficios
físicos y mentales de yoga que la idea
de compartirlo con las personas si me
atraían
pero como dije soy estudiante de obra
y siempre estoy buscando algo nuevo que
aprender
y un día encontrará un nuevo taller
que ofrece otro tipo de yoga que si me
interesaba
me puse en contacto con la dueña del
taller
acordamos vernos en su próxima clase
excelente
unos días después yo recibí una txapela
diciendo que ya había visto en mi página
de facebook enseñaba yoga en otro taller
y pensó que era muy poco ética de mi
parte haber querido aprender con ella y
muchas gracias ya no era bienvenida en
su clase
pueden imaginar cómo me sentía
para mí el yoga te expone los
fundamentos del bienestar y la comunidad
humana
yo me sentía tan traicionada
tanto yo casi deje que whatsapp de cinco
líneas me robar de lo que ha sido para
mí o santuario mental y físico para casi
la mitad de mi vida
este pequeño historia
villava la idea que quiere compartir con
ustedes hoy
esto qué pasó me hizo pensar qué
todos nosotros tenemos ideas tenemos
proyectos tenemos emprendimientos como
la dueña y su taller
que queremos volver realidad crecer ser
exitosos y somos guerreros
escaneando el horizonte para potenciales
amenazas
pero
qué pasa si estas amenazas de los cuales
tenemos tanto miedo
no son amenazas sino
oportunidades para aliarnos y crecer
juntos
y claro
vemos todos he escuchado
los clichés de siempre
que juntos es mejor
entonces mejor
que solo llegas rápido pero juntos sigas
más lejos pero cuando debes compartir
algo de tu propia vida personal de tu
propio emprendimiento es difícil pensar
en sí no
pero sí
una mente creativa una mente cooperativa
genera más creatividad genera más
innovación y de hecho esta innovación
está escrita creatividad está dentro de
la buena realidad ahí pides ayuda a y
entiendes tus fortalezas y sus
debilidades y todo donde tal vez
necesitas otra perspectiva
pero claro es difícil pero ojalá esta
charla te ayudará a analizar tu propia
vida
personal y profesional porque sí sin
abrirte y estar abierto a las
oportunidades que te rodea
no puedes recibir ni ofrecer
bueno y como todos ustedes yo soy más
que solo una cosa y soy practicante de
yoga
tanto como inversionista de
emprendimiento de impacto
he visto este mismo fenómeno encerrarte
en el mundo de emprendimiento e
inversión
y como pueden imaginar la pregunta que
siempre recibo yo que más recibe yo es
como traigo la inversión como traiga en
la plata grande
esta mentalidad de alianzas
es clave
tres lecciones quiero compartir con
ustedes hoy que aprendiendo yo después
de escuchar cientos de empleadores y
trabajar con varios inversionistas y
donantes en este espacio uno piense en
grande
2 tratar de oportunidades no amenazas y
se flexible
primero
piensa en grande
yo vivo en loja
y en los últimos cinco años la hoja ha
visto crecimiento de producción y
consumo de cerveza artesanal
uno de los mejores amigos tiene una
cervecería artesanal y con este
crecimiento
ha pedido una sofía de las experiencias
personas pretendiendo ser amigos para
aprender de ellos y sin decirles abrir
un local competidor
pero
una oportunidad recién ha surgido la
feria de loja y es uno de los eventos
más grandes de loja de la ciudad ha
ofrecido destacar las cervecerías
artesanales en lugar de las grandes
marcas
necesita una cantidad de cerveza tiene
una cervecería artesanal puede producir
solo
para aprovechar de esta oportunidad
tienen que juntarse dejar de lado sus
quejas pasadas y aliarse para crecer
juntos
ella aquí llegues a este gran punto
piensa en grande inversionistas quieren
crecimiento quieren grandes números
grandes mercados
pero una vez que tu mercado es más que
sólo una porción de 180.000 lojanos si
no todo el ecuador o toda la región de
américa latina o todo el mundo
ahí tienes que estar pensando en
alianzas para atender tu mercado
tratar de oportunidades no amenazas
quiero contar la historia de hipocampos
learning sanderson
invocamos turning centers tiene un
modelo de educación privada
para atender las necesidades de
educación de los más pobres en india
en méxico unos emprendedores amigos míos
también han encontrado este mismo
problema esta misma oportunidad hicieron
su deber y encontraron el modelo de
equipo campus learning centers
pero en lugar de verlos como de amenazas
que pasa así porque estuvieron en
centros crecen más allá de quiere llegar
a méxico qué hacemos
vieron ejemplo campos como una
oportunidad de aliarse
louis
el emprendedor
en méxico se puso en contacto con un mes
el otro señor con lentes en la foto y un
mes estaba emocionadísima
de la idea
el año pasado
equipo campos centros de aprendizaje
abierto sus primeros cuatro escuelas
al menos la mitad del tiempo que tomó en
india
vieron allí tocamos como un potencial
aliado y si llegaran a su meta de una
manera mucho más eficiente
finalmente se flexibles
house es un emprendimiento que tiene
como misión atender las necesidades de
salud de los más pobres en el mundo
iniciando en india
con esta emisión podrían haber dicho ok
abrimos una clínica para los pobres pues
es terrible
directamente de competición con las
clínicas públicas en india que ya tiene
un alcance de millones de millones
de pobres
entonces lo que hicieran era fueron
flexibles con su misión sin demoraron de
un problema se sumergieron en las
clínicas públicos bien de nadie los que
estas clínicas como potenciales aliados
y se dieron cuenta de algo
se dieron cuenta que la mayoría de los
pacientes
en india post operatorios son como
aquí el bebé que se fue a la clínica
para una cirugía de corazón pero la
mayoría de estos pacientes se quedan
solos
la mayoría del día
mientras al otro lado de la pared
dentro del pasillo dentro de la sala de
espera está la familia montón de gente
todos nerviosos todos ansiosos todos
aburridos
durante él se vio este problema
y ahora está transformando estos salas
de espera en salas de capacitación
mientras su familia está esperando
capacitar a la familia en la situación
de salud del paciente como tomar signos
vitales como manu trillar el paciente en
casa y lo más emocionante que nada está
salvando vidas en los hospitales donde
está presente en dura
ha bajado
el porcentaje de complicaciones puesto
laboratorios un buen indicador de la
mortalidad por más de 70 por ciento
increíble y los pactos que ha tenido al
ser flexible
repito las tres elecciones
piensa en grande
tratar de oportunidades no amenazas tres
de flexibles
no flexible loco
pero si flexible con una mente abierta
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]